CARA SWITCHER IS HERE ON THAT
AND THE COMPANY FORMALLY KNOWN
AS FACEBOOK.
AND LASTLY, WHAT IS PUNDITS
THINKING, WHAT IS HE TAKING A
STAND FOR?
>>> BUT FIRST, WAS THE PEACEFUL
POWER IN JANUARY SOMETHING OF A
MIRACLE, AND WILL IT BE
REPEATED?
LET ME EXPLAIN WHY I'M ASKING.
THE DETERIORATION OF DEMOCRACY
IS A DAILY STORY IN AMERICA.
LOOK AT A POLITICO HEADLINE FROM
THE OTHER DAY ABOUT JUST HOW
CONSPIRATORIAL TRUMP WORLD HAS
BECOME.
THE HEADLINE SAYS, AS FEAR GROWS
IN TRUMP WORLD, HAVE WE GONE TOO
CON SPIRITTORIAL?"
INTERESTING QUESTION BECAUSE ON
THE VERY SAME DAY, TRUMP DROPPED
THIS FOR PATRIOT PURGE, AN
EXTREMIST SERIES.
GOES FULL 1/6 DENIALISM.
RIOT DENIALISM, ELECTION
DENIALISM, IT IS ALL OF A PIECE.
AND SOME ANCHORS AND WRITERS ARE
TRYING TO EXPOSE THAT, TRYING TO
TO OPPOSE THOSE FEARS OF
DEMOCRACY.
SAYING DONALD TRUMP'S
SLOW-MOTION COUP IS BECOMING A
RUNAWAY TRAIN.
BUT I HAVE TO TELL YOU
SOMETHING, THERE ARE OTHER
JOURNALISTS OUTSIDE OF CNN WHO
SEE WHAT IS HAPPENING, WHO SEE
THE CONSPIRACY CLOUDS FORMING,
WHO SEE THE ELECTION SUBVERSION
EFFORTS INTENSIFYING AND THEY
DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY CAN SAY SO,
THEY FEEL CONSTRAINED.
I HAD ABOUT A HALF DOZEN
CONVERSATIONS WITH A-LIST
JOURNALISTS ABOUT THIS IN THE
PAST MONTH.
THEY TELL ME IN PRIVATE THAT
THEIR NEWS OUTLETS ARE
STRUGGLING OVER HOW TO COVER
THIS DAILY ASSAULT ON DEMOCRACY,
THIS DRIP, DRIP, DRIP.
WELL, ONE WAY TO DO IT IS BY
MAPPING OUT THE ROAD AHEAD.
LET'S LOOK AT THE STOPS ALONG
THE WAY.
BECAUSE SO MUCH MIGHT HAPPEN IN
THE NEXT THREE YEARS IS SADLY
PREDICTABLE.
IMAGINE IT'S 2022.
RIGHT WING MEDIA KEEPS PUMMELING
PRESIDENT BIDEN, WEAKENING HIM,
CALLING HIM A TYRANT ONE MINUTE
AND SENILE THE NEXT.
DONALD TRUMP IS IN COMPLETE
CONTROL OF THE GOP AND HIS
ENTIRE POLITICAL EXISTENCE IS
PREMISED ON THE BIG LIE.
HE LAUNCHES HIS OWN VERSION OF
TWITTER AND STREAMS A TALK SHOW
ON THE WEB AND IT DOESN'T GET AS
MANY VIEWERS AS FOX BUT IT SETS
THE AGENDA ON THE HARD RIGHT AND
THE AGENDA IS REVENGE, TAKING
BACK WHAT HE SAYS WAS STOLEN.
BIG LINES RALLYING CRIES
SUPPLIES YEARS WORTH OF
HEADLINES FOR MAGA MEDIA.
AND THEY HOLD ON TO KEEP THEIR
JOBS.
TRUMPERS LIKE SEAN HANNITY ARE
IMPORTANT, ATTACKING DISSENTERS
FOR DARING TO STRAY.
SOME HAVE TO LEAVE THE PARTY.
TRUMP CONTINUES TO TRAVERSE THE
COUNTRY, HOLDING RALLIES UNDER
THE BANNER SAVE AMERICA, MIDDLE
EASTERNING AMERICA IS UNDER SUCH
DIRE THREAT THEY NEED TO BE
SAVED BY DEMOCRATS.
THESE ARE ON NEWSMAX AND ONN AND
STREAMED ALL OVER THE PLACE.
AND THEY CONTINUE TO PLACE NEW
RESTRICTIONS ON VOTING RIGHTS
WITH LOCAL RADIO HOSTS AND
COMMENTATORS PROVIDING ALL OF
THE RHETORICAL COVER THIS
SEASON.
THE SAVVY ONES SAY IT'S ABOUT
VOTER INTEGRITY.
THE CUTER ONES SAY IT'S BEEN
MAKING SURE REAL AMERICANS ARE
HEARD AND ILLEGALS ARE NOT.
EVEN IF REPUBLICANS ARE CHARGED
WITH ILLEGAL VOTING, EVEN WHEN
IT'S REPUBLICANS DOING IT, THEY
CLAIM DEMOCRATS ARE THE REAL
CRIMINALS.
IN THE RIGHT MEDIA ECHO CHAMBER
THE WORLD DEMOCRATS CON FLAG
RATED CONSTANTLY SO THE OTHER
SIDE LOSES LEGITIMACY BIT BY
BIT.
THE GOP IS ON BOARD WITH THIS.
THEY'RE ON BOARD WITH A POWER
GRAB AT ALL COSTS, DRIVEN BY
2350ER OF A CHANGING COUNTRY,
FEAR PROPELLED BY THE LIKES OF
TUCKER CARLSON AND LAURA
INGRAHAM, WHO BRING UP THINGS
LIKE CARAVANS RIGHT AT KEY
MOMENTS DURING THE ELECTION.
AND ALL OF THIS IN 2022 HELP THE
GOP REGAIN CONTROL OF THE HOUSE.
MEMBERS OF THE JANUARY 6th
SEDITION CAUCUS ARE NOW IN
CONTROL OF THE BODY THAT
COMPLETES THE ELECTORAL PROCESS.
SOME DEMOCRATS FRET ABOUT WHAT
WILL HAPPEN IN 2024.
THEY WORRY IF THE
INSURRECTIONISTS WILL HAVE THE
UPPER HAND NEXT TIME BUT
REPRESENT IN TRUMP REALITY, UP
IS DOWN AND DAY IS NIGHT.
HIS PROPAGANDA MACHINE SO
THOROUGHLY REWRITES THE STORY OF
JANUARY 6th, MOST TRUMP FANS NOW
SAY THE RIOT WAS LEGITIMATE AND
A VIR CHUROUS ATTEMPT TO RIGHT
OR WRONG THE FELONIES, BRUTAL
INJURIES AND SUICIDES HAVE BEEN
WRITTEN OUT OF THE STORY.
THE RIOTERS HAVE BEEN TURNING TO
THE VICTIMS, AND MOST PEOPLE BY
THE END OF 2022 HAVE A SINKING
FEELING THAT MORE RIOTS ARE
AHEAD.
NOW IMAGINE IT'S 2023.
TRUMP OFFICIALLY ANNOUNCES HE'S
RUNNING AGAIN.
HE FACES ANOTHER CHALLENGER BUT
IT IS STILL HIS PARTY, PARTLY
BECAUSE HE'S GREAT FOR RIGHT
WING RATINGS AND CLICKS.
HE'S CONVINCED HIS BASE HE'S THE
ONLY ONE WHO COULD RESTORE THEM
TO POWER.
WHEN CRITICS DERIDE THE TRUMP
CULT, HIS SUPER FANS EMBRACE
THAT WORD.
THEY START PRINTING CULT
T-SHIRTS.
SOME GUZZLE RED KOOL-AID AT
RALLIES.
SOME EMBRACE THEMSELVES CALLING
THEMSELVES TRUMP ETS, PLEDGING
TO SHARE ONLY REAL NEWS ABOUT
THE CANDIDATES TO GET AROUND THE
CNNs OF THE WORLD.
OF COURSE, THEIR REAL NEWS IS
LARGELY MISINFORMATION.
MEANWHILE KEY ELECTION BOARDS
ARE RESHAPED IN TRUMP'S FAVOR
AND THE MAGA MEDIA MACHINE GINS
UP EVEN MORE HATRED GETS
LEGISLATORS IN STATES.
LEGISLATION IS ONE OF THE KEY
WEAPONS, CARS, BUSES, ALL MESS
IG WAYS.
BUT PRO-TRUMPERS SAY LIBERALS
THREATEN US TOO SO JUST GETTING
EVEN.
THERE'S ALWAYS AN EXCUSE
PROVIDED FOR UN-DEMOCRATIC
BEHAVIOR.
WHAT ABOUT ISM IS THE NAME OF
THE GAME, TURNING OUT SHELVES OF
BOOKS FOR EVERY LIBERAL INSTINCT
AND RELIGIOUS BLASTERS BLAST OUT
DAILY PROPHECIES ABOUT TRUMP
BEING GOD'S VESSEL AGAINST
DEMONIC DEMOCRATS.
THE AVERAGE "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
READER ALMOST NEVER SEES ANY OF
THIS BUT IT'S OUT THERE EVERY
DAY.
REMEMBER, IT'S 2023, GOP PRIMARY
SEASON, DEMOCRATS POINTING OUT
TRUMP IS A WANNA BE AUTOCRAT ARE
INSULTED BY FOX STARS,
TRIGGERING HATE CAMPAIGNS
AGAINST THEM.
REPORTERS TRYING TO COUNTER LIES
JEERED AND SMEARED MORE THAN
EVER BEFORE.
HIS VERBAL ATTACKS TO SEVERE,
BEATINGS AT RALLIES, BOMBS IN
NEWSROOMS.
THE BOMBS DON'T EXPLODE BUT
THAT'S BESIDES THE POINT.
FEAR IS THE POINT, SILENCE
THROUGH FORCE.
LET'S CONTINUE DOWN THE ROAD A
LITTLE FURTHER.
IMAGINE IT'S 2024 NOW.
TRUMP IS THE GOP NOMINEE.
HE'S FEEDING OFF BIDEN'S
MISSTEPS IN A FOREIGN CRISIS.
HIS BIG LIE FROM 2020 HAS BECOME
ABSOLUTE ACCEPTED TRUTH IN HIS
PARTY.
AND THERE'S A CLEAR DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE PEOPLE WHO PAY FOR
NEWS AND SUBSCRIBE TO NEWS
SOURCES AND WANT TO KNOW WHAT IS
TRUE VERSUS PEOPLE WHO PAY FOR
VIEWS, INCENDIARY VIEWS THAT
THEY WANT TO BE TRUE.
AND THAT'S WHAT MAGA MEDIA IS
ALL ABOUT, INCENDIARY VIEWS.
THERE'S A MARKET FOR THIS.
IT'S A GIANT GRIP.
EVEN MORE SAVE AMERICA WEBSITES
ARE LAUNCHING TO SELL
AFFIRMATION AND MERCH TOTZ
FATEFUL.
THESE GUYS DON'T CITE THE NEWS,
THEY SPIN THE NEWS IN TRUMP'S
FAVOR.
THEY START TO PUBLISH ENEMIES'
LISTS AND PEOPLE DREAM OF WHAT
THEY WILL DO IF TRUMP IS DENIED
POWER, WHICH WEAPONS THEY'LL
USE, WHO THEY WILL HURT.
AT FAR RIGHT CONFERENCES, PEOPLE
ASK WHEN DO WE GET TO USE THE
GUNS?
AND HOW MANY ELECTIONS ARE THEY
GOING TO STEAL BEFORE WE KILL
THESE PEOPLE?
AMERICANS ARE AT EACH OTHER'S
THROATS, SPUN UP BY THE SICK
STUFF THEY SEE ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
EVERY DAY SOME RANDOM HYPER
LOCAL STORY ABOUT A MIGRANT FROM
HAITI OR REFUGEE FROM
AFGHANISTAN IS BLOWN OUT OF
PROPORTION INTO SOME DOOMSDAY
INTERNATIONAL STORY ABOUT THE
DEATH OF WHITE AMERICA'S WAY OF
LIFE.
THIS IS ALL YOU HEAR ABOUT ON
RIGHT WING RAIDIA AND RUMBLE,
THEY'RE KILLING US, THAT'S THE
ELECTION NARRATIVE AND THIS 12U6
TRICKLES DOWN DESTROYING CIVIL
DISCOURSE, EVEN AT A LOCAL
LEVEL.
NEIGHBORS TURN ON NEIGHBORS.
NORMALLY EASY GOING ELECTIONS
TURN INTO EXISTENTIAL BATTLES.
IT FEELS LIKE THERE'S REPUBLICAN
BARS AND DEMOCRAT BARS, KMONG
GROUND EE ROADS LARGELY BECAUSE
THERE'S NO COMMON MEDIA GROUND
ANYMORE.
IT'S AS IF AMERICA'S BEEN
SWALLOWED UP BY QANON CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION FEELS
TRAMPLED, MUSCLED.
AND, REMEMBER, AS ALL OF THIS IS
HAPPENING, AS DEMOCRACY
DETERIORATES IN 2024, TRUMP'S
ENABLERS CLAIM THEY'RE THE ONES
PROTECTING DEMOCRACY.
THEY THINK, OR AT LEAST THEY
PRETEND, THEY'RE UPHOLDING THE
DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE.
THEY CLOAK THEIR AUTOCRATIC
ACTIONS IN THE LANGUAGE OF THE
FOUNDING FATHER.
THEY CLAIM TO BE THE MOST
PATRIOTIC AMERICANS OF THEM ALL
AND THIS NARRATIVE IS ADVANCED
24 HOURS A DAY BY THE ABC, THE
APPS, BROADCASTERS AND
COMMENTATORS WHO JUSTIFY
STUMPING ALL OVER THE
CONSTITUTION AS AN ATTEMPT TO
SAVE IT.
NOW IMAGINE IT'S ELECTION DAY
2024.
TRUMP IS THE LEADER OF A NEW
LOST-CAUSE MOVEMENT.
EVERY SINGLE VOICE ON FOX HAS
HIS BACK.
BUT OUTLETS LIKE OAN STILL CALL
FOX LIBERAL COMEY PINKIO
WHATEVER IT TAKES TO STEAL
VIEWERS FROM THE TOP CHANNEL AND
FOX RESPONDS BY MOVING EVEN
FURTHER TO THE RIGHT, QUAD
DRUPING DOWN ON RED MEAT OPINION
OVER NEWS.
THERE WILL BE NO REPEAT OF THE
ARIZONA RACE CALL.
TELLING THE TRUTH IS TOO RISKY.
THE GOPPERS WHO USED TO BE
RESPONSIBLE PARTY OFFICIALS ARE
YOU CARRERING TO TRUMP.
ELECTION BOARDS ARE, TO BORROW A
WORD, RIGGED.
BOARD UP DOWNTOWN WINDOWS.
MAYBE LOOTING STARTS.
I'M NOT SAYING ALL OF THIS WILL
HAPPEN, BUT I'M SAYING IT COULD.
WE KNOW IT COULD HAPPEN BECAUSE
IT'S ALL HAPPENED BEFORE.
ALMOST EVERYTHING I HAVE
DESCRIBED AS ALREADY HAPPENED IN
ONE FORM OR ANOTHER.
BOOKS LIKE "PERIL" HAVE ALL OF
THE EVIDENCE AND THE NEXT BIG
BOOK ABOUT TRUMP AND ELECTION
DEVERSION IS "BETRAYAL" BY
JONATHAN CARL.
IT COMES OUT IN NOVEMBER.
IT HAS EVEN MORE EVIDENCE OF
TRUMP BETRAYING DEMOCRACY.
KARL WRITES IN HIS FINAL CHAPTER
THAT TRUMP CAME SO CLOSE TO THE
EDGE LAST WINTER, CLOSER THAN
MOST AMERICANS APPRECIATE.
I WANT TO READ TO YOU ONE LINE
FROM WHAT KARL SAYS.
HE SAYS, QUOTE, I DIDN'T REALIZE
IT AT THE TIME BUT AS I REPORTED
ON THIS BOOK, BECAME CONVINCED
THAT THE PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF
POWER THAT HAPPENED AS SCHEDULED
ON JANUARY 20th WAS SOMETHING OF
A MIRACLE.
WE KNOW WHAT TRUMP WILL DO, SO
WHAT W